[music]
>> Hello and welcome to another episode of
What's Up Prof.
Good day, Walter.
Good day, Martin.
We haven't had the opportunity to say hi
to each other even though it was still
airing the whole time, but we had a
a whole trip where we were
greeting each other in other countries.
Correct. [snorts]
New Zealand and Australia.
I'm glad we went. Mhm.
And I'm glad we could meet all those
people.
Yeah, it was
>> And I get a very strong feeling that the
world is ready for the coming of the
Lord.
>> Oh, that's for sure. That's true.
Another thing that was all interesting
is when we were there
um
they are people that have printed an a
Bible, King James Bible.
>> yes. Yeah.
A blue one.
And it's a very
very nice Bible and it's on
very good paper.
And it's got the letters of Jesus' words
in blue. Yes, and the reason why they
chose blue is because blue is the color
of obedience. Yeah.
And the color of the law, the
commandments.
And it has many quotes from the spirit
of prophecy in it. And a series
of Bible studies in the back that are
very
uh succinct and very good.
And I certainly can recommend this Bible
and they're doing it basically
at cost. So, this is really a wonderful
project
that people can support. The writing is
large enough for people with
bad eyes like me. I'm also getting
there. Are you getting there? Come on.
>> [laughter]
>> And really we can recommend this Bible.
I think Martin we have more or less
decided that we will
we will try and get hold of a whole
a lot of them and distribute them.
Yeah. From our end and uh Yeah, I think
people from all over we'll put the
contact details in from where they can
get more information about it, but they
can ship anywhere in the world probably.
>> Anywhere in the world. It's a beautiful
project and I think it can
can do well and I think it deserves
support. That's it. So, just a thank you
to all of the people for all the
arrangements and it was I think a very
blessed time that
>> Yes. God was good and I'm sure that uh
there will be
uh results. I hope so. Well, why while
we were there
I remember what we were
you were just about to go on
for your one lecture
and then it came
the news that Israel and the US struck
Iran.
>> Yes, it was that very day that
uh the strike in Iran began.
So, we thought we would have a little
chat about it, world at stake.
Is the world at stake? Is the world
going to unify eventually?
And uh the kings of the world have one
mind in order to get rid of something
that is troublesome and bothersome for
this world.
Pestilent.
>> huh? Pestilent.
>> Pestilent fellows.
Just like they're getting rid of
something that is bothersome and
troublesome at the moment. And I'm
surprised at the rhetoric
at the way they address these people,
you know, as though they really have no
right to exist with the mindset that
they have. Now, not that we are taking
sides with mindsets or anything like
that. We must make that very clear
because
>> very clear, yeah.
>> people can will try and jump on and say,
"Oh, but you've chosen this side."
>> No, we've chosen no side. We are looking
at the events from a prophetic
perspective.
And so, what is really at stake here?
And
why is this titled that the whole world
is basically at stake?
Because the whole world is going to make
a decision. Mhm. And this this war
is a religious war.
It's a religious war. That's where it
comes in. It's the most important thing
to realize that, otherwise you'll be
lost in all the other stuff.
>> You'll get lost in the quagmire. Now,
we're going to try and make the point
and again there will of course be people
that disagree
and people that see it otherwise and at
no time are we declaring ourselves
oracles saying [snorts] that we have you
know, the ultimate answer to all of
this, but this is our best estimate
in terms of the prophetic profile. So,
let's jump right into it, Martin, and
see where this is going and why we say
it is a religious war
and what the outcome will be.
But before we do that, I think we need
to pray. Amen. Definitely.
>> And seeing you always pray in the
beginning and I close with prayer,
it is your privilege to pray.
>> Thank you.
Our heavenly Father, it is indeed a
privilege to talk to you and it's a
privilege to work for you.
And we're living in such momentous
times, so we ask that you guide us, lead
us be with us and protect us in Jesus'
name. Amen. Amen.
Okay, Martin, let's have a look at this
picture. This is a hypothetical
portrayal of the final kingdom of God on
this earth, right?
And this kingdom is in juxtaposition to
another kingdom. Uh-huh. And that is the
kingdom of
the devil.
And
if we read our Bible correctly, then the
kings of the world are in cahoots
with that kingdom
arrayed against the kingdom of God
because they make war against the lamb.
>> Yeah.
But the lamb will overcome them.
So, the final conflict is between the
choice of two kingdoms and two
[clears throat] kings. A kingdom on
earth
and a heavenly kingdom that will be set
up by Christ.
Now, the Old Testament battles serve as
a type for the final confrontation,
right? So, every earthly support will be
cut off and you will not be able to buy
or sell
if you choose obedience to the rules and
regulations of the kingdom of God
as opposed to the rules and regulation
of another kingdom presided over by
another king Mhm.
who is a proxy to the dragon. Uh-huh.
That's a lot of talk that you've just
given there. Yes. Yeah. Should we unpack
it a little bit?
>> a little bit, please.
All right. So, basically the Bible talks
about the Antichrist
the little horn power of Daniel chapter
uh the beast power of Revelation chapter
who ruled the the world in the Middle
Ages, received a mortal wound. The
mortal wound will be healed and the
kings of the world will give their power
unto him and he will again sit crowned
and rule the world in terms of its
morality. Through a proxy. Through many
proxies, but they will give their power
unto him
and his mark of authority, which we have
repeatedly shown is the Sabbath
uh the Sunday versus the Sabbath will be
enforced and if you do not accept his
authority, you won't be able to buy or
sell.
>> That's it. And eventually you will get a
death decree.
Now, if we look at Iran
is there basically a death decree
against a certain ideology? Yeah.
So, there must be something about the
ideology that doesn't fit into the
framework, right?
>> That's it. We'll have to look at that.
And we know that the whole world will be
arrayed against Christ. Revelation 13:3,
12, all of these issues. Revelation
chapter 17.
There's a conflict between the dragon
and Christ
and the church of Christ and the
proxies.
Okay. And then there will be a death
decree pronounced against those that
don't want to play ball.
That's Revelation 13:15.
And what can God's people do under the
circumstances? They don't have missiles.
They don't have ballistic missiles. They
don't have enriched uranium.
They have none of those things. So, the
only thing that they have is the promise
that God will take care of them.
And all they can say is what we read in
2 Chronicles chapter 20:12.
Oh, our God, wilt thou not judge them?
For we have no might against this great
company that cometh against us, neither
know we what to do.
But our eyes are upon thee.
That's our only hope, right?
So, Martin, we're going to move down the
pariahs to become the ultimate pariah.
And what is our great crime?
Not knuckling under to the laws of men
in opposition to the laws of God.
Because the remnant keeps the
commandments of God and holds to the
testimony of Jesus.
Trouble of Israel.
So, Martin, the only way in which we can
face the coming crisis is to remember
where we come from.
So, that we know where we're going.
He's the potter.
We are the clay.
He's the creator.
We are the creature. Did he set the
memorial for creation?
Is that to remind us where we come from?
Remember the Sabbath. Not until we
realize our total dependence and find
nothing within ourselves
to commend us
can we truly rest in him.
This is the meaning of the Sabbath. It
is a sign that we acknowledge that he is
the Lord that sanctifies us. So, it's a
very, very, very important
precept.
And if you try to circumvent it, you are
circumventing your origin and your
dependence and the your very existence.
The Bible is straightforward on the
Sabbath. It's straightforward. I don't
I've never seen any verse on the Sabbath
that's obscure or you have to okay,
what's actually being said here. No, you
can't twist it round to say something
else. To get rid of the Sabbath, they do
like you always say, verbal gymnastics.
Yes.
Verses in that doesn't have anything to
do with it. Now, let's take this verse
in Ezekiel chapter 20:12.
Moreover, I also gave them my Sabbaths.
Now, the argument of the evangelical
world and of the papacy is that this
applies to Israel.
But didn't he give it to Adam?
100%. There was no Jew on earth when the
Sabbath was instituted. No, there was an
Adam.
Fascinating.
>> Human for humankind the Sabbath was
there. Yes, that's right. Now, Martin,
he's the potter and we are the clay,
right?
>> [clears throat]
>> And in a sense, he had to take an
earthen vessel
so that he could pay the price for us
because God can't die.
So, humanity had to die. So, divinity
was blended with humanity so that
humanity
in humanity divinity could pay the
price. Amazing, amazing story. So, he
gave them the Sabbaths to be a sign
between him and them
so that they might know that he is the
Lord that sanctifies them. So, not only
is the Sabbath creation
a reminder of creation
it's also a reminder of salvation as to
how we become
sanctified.
Back in harmony with the principles of
God.
So, there's no way that you can shift
the Sabbath into any other
forum.
So, Martin, the rise of Christian
dominionism.
We have two kingdoms in juxtaposition
here.
The dominionists believe there are many
forms of dominionism.
And there are many forms of of theology
in which they unpack this so that
everybody has a little bit of the
smorgasbord.
>> Yeah, so everybody can be catered for.
>> Everybody can take a morsel, whatever
suits him the best. So, the one theory
is the Christian church will be
raptured.
And only the Jews and the pagan nations
remain. And then for a thousand years,
this plays out until everybody is
converted.
And then
the kingdom of God will be set in place.
So, for the next thousand years
there won't be any Christian church
around. That's one form. That's not the
Catholic view.
Catholic view is amillennialism. There
is no millennium.
So, if there is no millennium, then how
does this play out? Well, the church
rules the world.
Forever. That's the other extreme.
Now, the evangelicals, of course,
realize that there is a millennium.
So, how does that play out? The one
group says, well, the church is
raptured. The other group says, no,
we're going to we're going to organize
this as follows.
The church will rule.
And the church remains here and the
church rules. But obviously, the church
can only rule in the Christian era, in
the Christian areas.
And the Jews will have to move to
Palestine and they will have to rule
there. And the other nations around will
have to have their systems for a
thousand years.
And eventually, some believe, like
Wilson said to us in our interview
that it might take another 250 years or
so until the the church has finally
converted the world. So, at some stage
this conversion will take place. But the
ruling power will be the Christian world
down here on earth. So, that's basically
the 10 horns, right?
And if you don't adhere to their rules,
you will be sorted out.
>> You will be sorted out.
So, the rise of Christian dominionism.
Jerry Falwell wanted to prepare America
for the end of the world.
Ted Cruz's evangelical backers want to
take America over.
So, this was now before the elections,
but this is the mindset that they had.
Cruz, who has suggested he might run in
2024,
which he did for a while and then
withdrew
represents a more recently ascended
evangelical worldview quite different
from dispensationalism.
That's what we've just discussed.
Christian dominionism.
This is the belief that Christians
should take moral, spiritual, and
ecclesiastical control over society.
This is one of the pivots of the ruling
power. Now, if you mix this with
Catholicism
This is protestantized Catholicism.
Can we say it that way?
So, basically, this is a marriage
between evangelical thinking and
Catholic thinking, right?
And by the way, the Lutherans had the
same opinion as the Catholics had. In
other words, there is no specific
millennium.
So, because the Bible is so clear on a
specific millennium
there is this marriage now here.
So, they still throw the thousand years,
but the church is in control. And the
church prescribes morality. That's where
we're heading.
That's what they want.
Now, Martin, we've moved into a new
phase.
And there is no more a Department of
Defense. It is now a Department of War.
Right?
And the leader is a very
interesting person, Hegseth, who has
been chosen to be the leader.
And he has some very interesting tattoos
which show basically Catholic knighthood
roots.
And he wrote a book called American
Crusade.
Now, the Crusades were undertaken to get
control over Jerusalem
and were basically involved against the
Muslim world, et cetera, et cetera,
about the control of Jerusalem.
So, fascinating that he changed the name
to the Department of War
and put this very specific mindset,
in other words, American Crusade
in in place.
They're in offense. And now they've
brought out the new dime.
And this is, of course, to commemorate
the 250th year of American
existence, as it were.
And this is what the new dime actually
looks like. And it's very fascinating.
Because on the reverse side of this
dime, you have the eagle, which is a
symbol of the United States.
But of course it was also a symbol of
Rome.
>> Mhm.
All right? Yes. And then eventually then
um Correct. Nazis as well. So it is
basically the Roman eagle.
Okay, Martin.
Interestingly, this eagle always used to
have the arrows
which stand for offense.
>> Uh-huh.
And in the other claw it used to have
the olive branch which was peace.
>> Peace, yeah.
And now the olive branch has been
removed.
>> Yeah.
And they're quite blatant about it.
Now the front of the coin is very
interesting as well because they claim
that this is Lady Liberty.
>> Mhm.
Although she's a very masculinized
Lady Liberty, would you agree? And
because you know
Lucifer is androgenic.
Is both of them. So in the new face
design, a determined Lady Liberty turns
to the right as tailwinds push strands
of her hair forward. So the wind is in
her back.
>> [snorts]
>> She's moving at a speed.
On the reverse, an eagle in flight
carries arrows in its talons on one foot
and looks back at the other foot which
is notably clutching nothing.
The US Mint description of the dime says
the eagle with arrows represents the
American Revolution and colonists fight
for independence.
Of course the 13 were the original
colonies. That existed in the United
States. Of course today there are 50.
They really want to increase it to 51 or
52 by incorporating
Canada and Greenland. But leave it at
that. It doesn't matter. The 13 was the
original but an arrow is a symbol
of war as well.
So peace through strength.
But what they want is they want liberty.
Yeah, there's no peace in this on this
coin anymore. Okay.
>> There's only strength. Now if you look
at the face on the dime and you compare
it with the old dime
where you had Roosevelt, President
Roosevelt on the front and you
definitely still had the olive leaf on
the back.
Now you've moved to this so-called lady.
But she has this interesting hairdo or
cap on which has this little blob over
there.
And this definitely is a very very
striking resemblance to the god Pan.
And the the Phrygian hat. Yes, and the
Phrygian hat.
Now we know what the symbolism of that
entails. It's actually the worship of
Lucifer.
And
in on the old coin, you had the flame of
liberty which is also the flame of
Lucifer.
And the Statue of Liberty with that
crown around it was the statue of Mitra.
Now
being androgenic, it is also a
masculinized
femininity.
If I can put it that way. Like this is
also a masculinized
femininity.
So let's just go back to Freemasonry and
see what they are talking about. The
symbols came to have two meanings. The
esoteric and the exoteric.
The esoteric meaning was the true or
original meaning understood only by a
few
and closely guarded by them. The
exoteric meaning was the invented or
modified explanation intended for the
many.
The sacred mysteries which are often
mentioned in connection with many
ancient religions and which were closely
guarded by the initiate
concerned esoteric meaning in the
religions of previous times.
The sacred mysteries very often were
merely continuations of the simpler
forms of early sex worship carried on by
a select few.
All right. So that explains the
androgenic aspects of it. The male
female like Baphomet is both male and
female.
And
the religion of Lucifer is a worship of
sex.
Now if we go to the Knights Templars,
then the Templars like all other secret
orders and associations had two
doctrines.
One concealed and reserved for the
masters which was Johannism.
And the other public which was Roman
Catholic. This comes from Morals and
Dogma. This is basically the Bible of
Freemasonry written by Albert Pike. A
channeled book by the way. So in other
words dictated by Lucifer himself, the
devil.
All right. What is Johannism?
Well
Johannism is a reference to John the
Baptist, right?
Now what happened to John the Baptist,
Martin?
>> He was beheaded.
Uh
but on the instigation of whom? By the
Well, can we put it the church and
state?
All right. So there was a lady there who
represents a church and her name was
Herodias. And she was in an illicit
relationship with the king.
>> Yeah. So that represents the church in
an illicit relationship with the state.
>> Mhm.
But there was a daughter. Yes. And her
name was Salome.
And she's the one that danced before the
king.
>> [cough]
>> Now does the Roman Catholic Church claim
to be the mother of the churches? Yes.
Does she say other churches are not
sisters but daughters?
>> Yes. So Ratzinger who became Pope
Benedict
said that other churches are not
sisters, they're daughters.
Implying that the Protestant churches
are daughters of the Catholic Church.
Now
which church is dancing before the
kings? Isn't it the Protestant world?
>> All right. The evangelicals.
>> Uh-huh. The faith-based um
Yeah.
>> department and all. Is it possible that
they're going to ask for the head of
John the Baptist?
>> Yes. Johannism.
All right. Now Johannism
John lost his head. John the Baptist
lost his head.
So that was actually a victory of Satan
over those that are heralding the coming
of Christ and his kingdom.
>> Yeah.
We did the third Elijah Mhm. where the
second Elijah was John the Baptist and
the third Elijah is the church now.
>> Johannism is actually a symbol of the
victory of Lucifer over Christ and his
followers.
It is a victory over his kingdom setting
up their own kingdom.
Now
in one of the churches,
a very prominent one in Germany where
the political leaders all come together
to make political decisions. Interesting
that they always choose venues like
that.
I found this statue on the outside in
the in the courtyard.
And it supposedly depicted
the good shepherd with his sheep
carrying the sheep, right?
And it was
>> [snorts]
>> stated that this was a statue of David
as the shepherd.
But unfortunately, in his hand he has a
pan flute.
Now
>> David did not play a pan flute. No.
David never played a pan flute. He
played the harp.
So Martin, this is a depiction of the
good side
the white side if you like
of the god Pan playing the pan flute and
pretending to be like Christ. In other
[clears throat] words, the good
shepherd.
So I thought about it and I said, "Well,
if this is Pan
then somewhere in this building, I
should find his opposite evil entity.
The yin yang.
And that should be the goat
with the pan flute.
Now there it sits and it's on one of the
pillars. There you have the god Pan with
his goat's feet.
And he is the evil side.
So Martin, this is the worship of good
and evil, the knowledge of good and
evil. This is the worship of Lucifer.
And it's very plainly depicted. And you
also had a depiction of the god Janus
the two-headed one. It can be facing the
one way or the other way. The good side,
the white side, the black side, black
magic, white magic, white witches, black
witches, you know, all of that all mixed
together.
So the god Pan, what is he doing on this
coin?
If we go back in history and you get to
the black obelisk of Shalmaneser the
third
where it shows Jehu paying tribute to
the king Shalmaneser.
Now the sad thing about this, Martin, is
that this was an Israelite king.
Right?
And here he is bowing down to
Shalmaneser
and he has a Phrygian hat on.
Now, that is a symbol
of freedom.
You can rule
subject
to this individual over here on the
left.
So, you may rule, but you are a subject.
And these are the ones following after
bringing tribute and they all have the
Phrygian cap
which is a symbol of the secret worship
of this other entity, this deity that
grants you liberty on condition. Yeah.
That you adhere to the common good, for
instance.
>> All right. Now,
does God grant you liberty also on
condition?
Yes. Yes, condition of obedience.
>> Obedience to his law. So, Satan wants to
be like the most high, but he has a
different law. Yeah.
So, this is all very fascinating
history.
So, fascinatingly, this
kind of hat that you find on the god
Pan, you will also find on the god
Mithra.
And the Statue of Liberty is actually a
depiction
of the god Mithra and you can see that
Lady Liberty has a masculine face.
And she bears the torch which is the
flame of Lucifer, the flame of liberty.
Now, the United States Senate also has
as its symbol the Phrygian hat.
And the Department of the Army has the
same as you can see over there.
And they are subject to this serpent.
Are you subject to a serpent? Martin?
So, this is an esoteric doctrine.
>> Yeah. It's not an exoteric doctrine.
>> the insider. This is for the insiders.
Now, the BBT reports that Trump has a
24-karat gold medal approved by
hand-picked federal panel.
So, the commemorative gold coin bearing
the image of the United States President
Donald Trump has been approved by
Federal Arts Commission.
It's a 24-karat gold coin. It's intended
to mark the 250th birthday, the 4th of
July,
of the United States
and portrays Trump with his fist pressed
against the desk. Is that a sign of
determination? Yes, definitely the
arrows.
It's not a peace sign.
>> So, the peace is gone
and the war has commenced. So, Martin,
this is the final battle.
This is the final battle. If I may be so
bold
as to take the Bible in hand,
I could take the blue one now. I'll take
the blue one. You'll take the blue one
and you go back to where we always go,
Daniel chapter 11.
>> [snorts]
>> And we talk about this king
who is the antitype of this Shalmaneser.
Yes, this is the this king of Assyria
and later was superseded by the king of
Babylon.
And the Bible makes it quite clear that
Rome is Babylon. Peter refers to Rome as
Babylon.
And he is the king of the north.
Even though others seem to want to
differ on that issue.
He is the king of the north. Now, what
is this king of the north going to do
at the end?
Well, verse 36 tells us that the king
shall do according to his will.
He shall exalt himself and magnify
himself above every god.
He shall speak marvelous things against
the god of gods. This is a depiction of
the little horn power of Daniel chapter
with these attributes of changing the
law of God, doing what he wants to
and basically
denying the authority of God and putting
his own authority in its place.
So, verse 37 tells us that he will not
regard the god of his fathers.
But he will honor a god of forces.
Now, Martin, that is very interesting
because if he honors a god of forces,
if you look at the
subtitles or the explanations, then it
tells you munitions.
That's a military term.
So, this one has the power in his hand.
He has the power. The military power.
>> And he magnifies himself above
everything and then he has something
else.
Besides honoring this god of forces, he
will force you.
Jesus said, "When I be lifted up, I will
draw all men." Yeah, yeah.
Now, this one works the
other way.
He forces you. This one forces, right?
The other one draws.
Two different philosophies there.
But
he will not only use gold and pomp and
glamour to do this.
He will also do in most strongholds with
a strange god.
In other words, he is fighting on behalf
of a strange god.
There's only one that the Bible is
really concerned about, right? That's
Lucifer and Albert Pike
and Blavatsky make it quite clear that
Lucifer is their choice. That's the
choice of Freemasonry.
Although they tell their little
initiates something else.
Now, verse 40 says, "At the time of the
end,"
this [snorts] is where we are,
"shall the king of the south push
against him." And we've said that many
times, secularism.
Basically, we have a battle between the
Democrats and the Republicans, if you
want to put it in a in a political
framework.
"And he will come against him like a
whirlwind."
Against this mindset, in other words,
with chariots,
with horsemen,
with many ships.
So, he will use the economy
and he will use military might.
So, it can't be a Department of Defense.
No, it must be war. It must be a
Department of War.
And he will enter the glorious land and
he will stretch out and he'll take all
the nations.
And verse 43 says, "He shall have power
over the treasures of gold and silver."
So, who controls the economy? Yeah.
You don't do what I say, you get slapped
with
>> Exactly, tariffs. tariffs.
"And over all the precious things of
Egypt."
So, he has power over the economy. He
moves the economy as he wants to and he
can use it as a weapon.
Plus, he has military power. That's what
the Bible tells us, right?
>> [snorts]
>> And then he will plant his tabernacle in
the palace between the seas, that's the
nations, and the glorious holy mountain,
that's God's kingdom.
And he will stand in the holy place
as an abomination of desolation and then
his end will come, right?
Well, we are not far from all of those
things happening. Definitely not.
So, we have these things in place. We've
moved to the Department of War and we
are going to see a overrunning of any
obstacle in the way of this king.
Now, who's going to receive the Liberty
Medal for promoting religious liberty?
It's interesting, all of this medals and
coins and everything has to do with Lady
Liberty and Liberty. All right. Now,
who's being honored there? Yeah, and
this one. This one. The Pope is being
honored, right?
So, [snorts] who's going to give him
this medal?
The United States.
>> All right. By giving him this medal, do
they acknowledge him as some superior
entity? Oh, for sure.
Martin, do we have the picture? It's
like the Jehu in front of Shalmaneser.
All right. So, this is Shalmaneser.
Exactly. Or his antitype, let's put it
that way. The king of Babylon.
And he's going to be honored. So, on
July the 3rd,
just before. That's the day before July
the 4th. So, the real one
the real ruler will be acknowledged just
before. The Bible says they will give
their power
unto him, right?
Pope Leo will receive the 38th annual
Liberty Medal from the National
Constitution Center
on the eve of the 250th anniversary of
the founding of the United States.
So, the award recognizes the Holy
Father. That's a blasphemy in itself.
Yeah, completely. Because there's nobody
holy, not not one. There's only one
holy. It's God. And his father.
So, this award recognizes the Holy
Father's lifelong work promoting
religious liberty. Religious force,
Martin, because he's the god of forces.
And freedom of conscience and expression
around the world. How did they enforce
this freedom of conscience in the past.
>> You've got freedom of conscience and uh
as long as it falls in with their
conscience. As long as it falls in with
the common good. And if it doesn't, then
you you get a thumb screw
and a stretching
and eventually you get burned at the
stake, right?
So, Martin, all of this enshrined by
America's founders in the First
Amendment to the United States
Constitution,
said the National Constitution Center in
a statement. Now, Martin, wasn't this
Constitution particularly written in
order to get rid of the tyranny of papal
suppression in the Middle Ages?
>> That's why that
one founding father said that the blood
can be kept away
that raged in Europe. So, this religious
liberty really is a scam
because this religious liberty is
subject to obedience to the common good
as defined by Rome itself.
>> Yeah, this their system. You have to
adhere to that.
>> Now, it tells us here in The Intercept
that the military leaders in the United
States of America
see the Iran war as God's divine plan.
So, is this a religious war?
>> Yeah, for sure.
A chilling turn for Trump's fascism.
Now, fascism was the regime of Adolf
Hitler and Mussolini.
>> Yeah, yeah.
And Adolf Hitler made it quite plain
that he introduced the principles of the
Jesuits into his regime.
In fact, he called Himmler his Ignatius
Loyola.
>> Uh-huh.
Right?
>> Yeah.
And there were meetings between the
Nazis and Hitler and the Pope at the
time.
>> Mhm.
And in fact, the Pope was called
Hitler's Pope.
>> Yeah.
And after the war, the the Vatican
organized the ratlines
where all the Nazis escaped Uh-huh.
to Argentina and other parts of the
world, right?
The interesting outcome of this war that
happened there
uh was that the Jews returned to
Palestine.
>> Mhm. That that way was also opened.
>> All right. So, number one, the war saw
to that they were handed out.
>> Mhm.
And then post-war,
they were sent to Israel. Mhm. And the
state of Israel
was inaugurated
in '48.
>> Yeah. Right?
1948.
And it's interesting that the allies
>> [snorts]
>> had the blockades which saw to it that
this took place. Yeah.
So, it's almost as though the allies
completed the work that was begun by by
others in in Europe, right?
>> All right. Now, we're not going to talk
about Holocaust and all of those issues.
We're just going to look at the outcome.
>> Mhm.
So, here was a state. Whose theology was
it that the Jews should return to
Palestine? Was it Jesuit theology,
right? Yeah. The Bible mentions it
it
in Genesis 15, but that was for for a
previous
time, not now in 1948. Because Jesus
quite plainly declared, "Your house is
left to you desolate."
>> desolate. And Paul stated,
"It was necessary
that this message should be preached to
you, but seeing that you count yourself
unworthy to receive it, we turn to the
Gentiles."
>> Mhm.
So, the gospel went to the Gentiles
and both Jews that accepted Christ as
the Messiah and Gentiles became the
spiritual Israel
and literal Israel ceased to have any
part to play.
>> Yeah.
Except under the doctrine of
dispensationalism,
which is a Jesuit doctrine.
So, you have these three monotheistic
religions. You have Christianity.
Then you have Judaism and then you have
Islam.
Now, we've discussed the relationship
between Catholicism and Islam in
previous ones. We don't need to do that.
And in a world where you have these
three systems, they introduced something
called the Abrahamic Accord.
You can't call it the Christian Accord.
You have to go back to Abraham.
And
>> Because Jesus is not the center.
>> No, he's not the Abraham becomes the
center.
And then you can have the possibility of
having a Christian dominionist system in
Christian lands, a Islamic dominionist
systems in Islamic lands, and a Jewish
dominionism in
a newly created state, Israel,
which was funded masonically and
introduced masonically.
So, that's the history.
So, it tells us in this article that the
United States is waging a religious war.
It's very important that we understand
this.
This is at least how dozens of fanatical
US military commanders understand
President Donald Trump's illegal assault
on Iran.
A Messianic battle to bring about Jesus
Christ's return.
Now, this is also a distortion. Yep.
Because yes, this could be the ultimate
thinking.
But in the meantime, for a millennium,
the church has to rule.
President Trump has been anointed by
Jesus
to light the signal fire in Iran to
cause Armageddon and mark his return to
Earth. One military commander told his
combat unit which could be deployed to
fight in Iran at any moment, according
to a complaint reportedly filed by one
of the unit's officers to a military
watch group.
So, here they are seeing it as a
religious war. The Military Religious
Freedom Foundation
said it has been inundated with more
than 200 calls across dozens of military
installations, including 110 complaints
filed between Saturday morning and
Monday evening
from service members reporting their
commanders have invoked similar
extremist rhetoric of Christian Zionist
Messianism
when justifying the unprovoked war on
Iran.
So, [snorts] what is it about Iran
[clears throat]
that doesn't fit the picture?
They are the ones that are prohibiting
that area to become part of the
Abrahamic Accords.
>> Yes, because they are Shia Muslims and
Shia Muslims believe
that their Imams have to be from the
direct line of descendancy from
Muhammad.
>> Yeah. Whereas the Sunnis believe that
any chosen leader represents Islam and
doesn't have to be from this line. So,
this is an exclusive way of looking at
Islamic leadership.
And because they have the original idea
of the Jihadists that all infidels and
non-believers should be eradicated, so
that would include both Jews and
Christians, right?
Or any other form of religion that is
not Islam.
Now, that kind of thinking doesn't fit
into an ecumenical climate. It's not for
the common good, Martin.
And therefore, anybody with this
exclusive thinking pattern
must be eradicated.
And you just remove them off the face of
the earth. It's like a death decree.
If you want to be a leader and you want
to embrace that kind of theology, you
better paint a target on your back.
>> Yeah. You are going to be eliminated.
Yeah.
>> [snorts]
>> Either ostracized or
>> So, it doesn't matter what religion it
is.
If your religion says
that my way is the only way,
then you are going to be eradicated.
Is that Is that the message?
>> That's what we see.
All right. You're now talking with
people about people armed with rockets
and with possible nuclear weapons and
all of those things. But the ultimate
target is going to be someone else.
And it's now not
people don't want to accept that. They
say, "What
What is it about this small little group
that's so special?" Well, when they can
do this to this group,
>> Yeah.
they're going to do it to the others.
So, let's just make sure that the
politicians really believe
that this is a religious war.
Let's
look at what Graham has to say.
Arab countries in the region have been
more than disappointing. If the media
reports are true that if the Arab
countries are okay with Iran's Ayatollah
staying in power, I'm going to
reevaluate my entire opinion of the Arab
world alliance. I've tried to be very
hopeful to build on the Abraham Accords,
but this idea of saying one thing behind
closed doors and something else in
public is coming to an end. So, I've
called Arab um
allies and I said, "You need to correct
the record. If you don't understand this
is the biggest moment for change since
the fall of the Berlin Wall, you're
missing a lot. This is a religious war.
Who wins it at the end of the day? Do
the radical Islamic terrorists who want
to kill all the Jews because God told
them to? What we're facing right now is
a moment of decision that will set the
course of the future of the Middle East
for 1,000 years.
Is this a religious war from the Israeli
perspective or from the Orthodox Israeli
perspective?
The war in Iran now
for my point of view is the first
religious fundamentalist war world war.
Jewish fundamentalism, Christian
fundamentalism, and Jewish
fundamentalism at the battle at the
battle at the battle field.
It feels that way to
>> I'm sorry.
>> Yeah, it feels that way to me watching
this. That's exa For how long, Norm? For
1,000 years. Isn't that a millennial
statement?
>> Yeah, for a very strong one.
All right. Now, who's going to set this
course for the next 1,000 years? Because
according to this thinking, let me just
get this straight.
>> Mhm.
All these powers are going to still be
here. Yeah.
But Daniel chapter 2 says
that the Lord will set up a kingdom and
all the powers will be removed.
They will become dust like on a
threshing floor.
>> Yeah. Yeah. And the wind will come and
blow them
away. How many of them?
>> All. All. Yeah. But according to this
theology, they're all going to be here.
>> They're going to be ruling.
So, what is going to be set for the next
1,000 years?
According to
According to him, yes. A theology of
coexistence.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Right?
>> The Abrahamic Accord. Which is the
Abrahamic Accord
Iran is not in the Abrahamic Accord.
Now, who set up this Abrahamic Accord?
Trump.
>> Yes. On behalf of whom? The Catholic
Church. Is the Catholic Church involved
in the Abrahamic Accord?
>> Definitely. They've got um
that they that's the Christian Church
that's being built on the area. All
right, but it's built like a cathedral,
not like a Protestant church, right?
And we have said on numerous occasions
that the Abrahamic Accord is an accord
against the atonement.
>> Mhm.
Yeah, that's why Jesus is out of it.
Because Jesus can't be in there.
And uh we have said on numerous
occasions that the Catholic Church does
not believe in the atonement that Christ
died for you.
He died, yes, as the perfect sacrifice
and the perfect obedience, but he didn't
die for you. Now, we've received a lot
of criticism from many people and I read
some of the comments and they say,
"Where's the evidence of this?"
Well, they can just look at the lecture
on the atonement, which is in Darkness
Before Dawn,
the series that I did some years ago.
And in that there's a there is a lecture
called the atonement where all the
quotes from the Roman Catholic Church
are there
and citing that that is their specific
doctrine.
>> Yeah. And if they don't want to believe
that, they can just look at purgatory.
Exactly. Because at purgatory, you pay
for your sins that have been forgiven.
>> Forgiven.
So, in other words, that's a denial of
the atonement.
>> 100% because Jesus said, "I washed away
all
as if you never sinned. You will be
stand without spot or wrinkle because of
his righteousness." Correct. So, Norm,
the atonement is clearly prefigured in
the Old Testament.
>> Mhm.
Without the shedding of blood, there's
no forgiveness of sins.
You had a burnt offering
where basically
the the victim was burnt symbolizing the
death of Christ,
which sets you free
>> Mhm.
from the condemnation. Yeah. Then you
had the sin offering.
The sin offering, you confessed your
sins over the innocent victim. The
innocent victim died in your behalf and
your sins were forgiven.
Then you had the grain offering.
The grain also represents Christ who was
crushed and as a consequence, the
storehouses of grain are open to you.
So, all of that depicts the atonement in
the Old Testament.
So, Norm, they're setting up a kingdom
here
where Christian morality will be
exercised in Christian areas, the 10
horns.
>> Yeah.
Where Islamic theology will be exercised
in Islamic lands, but Iran has to come
on board.
>> Mhm.
And radical thinking that doesn't fit
into the pattern has to be removed.
And then you will have the Jewish state
with their third temple.
>> Mhm.
And the third temple, of course, is a
denial of the atonement.
>> No, 100%. Yeah. Yes.
Because all the types were fulfilled in
Christ and they are erecting the type
again. Exactly.
>> They want to bring it back and that
that's a slap in Jesus' face.
Now, here's an interesting discussion
between Tucker Carlson and Piers Morgan.
So, let's just look at that one. Yeah.
Just make uh disclaimer.
We don't back any of these people.
It's interesting to see how what he's
saying, Tucker, and how he's being
treated. So, it's not that we choose
sides, but we'll see later on. This is
really getting to where it will go. Any
dissent of their thinking, you will have
a problem. Yes. I criticized Shapiro and
Levin for losing control of their
emotions. I lost control of mine when I
said that. I shouldn't have said that.
I've apologized for it repeatedly. I'll
do so again. I'm sorry that I said that
because I don't hate Christian Zionists.
I'm deeply frustrated with some
evangelical leaders who are not
preaching Christianity, but some sick,
weird, culty version of it that puts
Benjamin Netanyahu ahead of Jesus. And
that's not Christianity. It's totally
wrong. And some of them are quite
ruthless uh I have learned personally.
Franklin Graham, for example, I went in
to see Trump. And Trump says, "I just
got a letter from Franklin Graham
calling you an anti-Semite." I don't
think that's Christianity. I just don't.
And I'm sorry that it makes Ted Cruz
mad. As for Ted Cruz, he says he's
running against me for president. I
almost want to run for president just to
debate Ted Cruz because I think it
[laughter] would go about the way it
went last time. And for my part, I
deeply enjoyed it, which is why I've
never tweeted about it because I just
keep that little spark of joy inside me
for rainy days and I think about that
conversation and smile. So, Norm, that
just goes to show that people are
confused about the narrative. It's a
thing. There are so many narratives.
>> There's now
multiple narratives. All right. Now,
which one is the real narrative? The
real narrative, of course, is that
Christ is coming to set up his kingdom.
>> His kingdom. And that all these kingdoms
will disappear. But that doesn't fit
into the framework of their thinking.
So, Ted Cruz being a dominionist and
basically believing in the Zionist ideal
of a Zionist state
uh where the Jews will be able to rule
according to their rules and dictates,
those are ideas that bring confusion in
the world, particularly in the light of
a movie, let's say, of Left Behind,
>> Mhm.
which is the other side of the coin
Yeah. of also Jesuit thinking. So, all
of this is is very, very confusing and I
can understand his confusion.
And then uh Tucker also has has many
questions as to will the real Jews
please stand up?
>> Yeah.
Who are the real Jews? Who are the real
descendants of Judah?
And you can get into big trouble when
you when you start reasoning like that.
I think that's probably why Franklin
Graham uh called him an anti-Semite
>> He called him an anti-Semite.
>> because he's questioning the narrative.
>> Correct. So, if you question Zionism,
then you become an anti-Semite. Is that
really true?
>> No, not at all. Do you hate somebody
because you just questioned it?
>> So, let's just hear what
uh Ted Cruz had to say.
And I will say on the right, I have seen
more anti-Semitism in the last 18 months
on the right. And it is growing and it
is gaining real purchase, especially
with young people. And it is being
spread by loud voices. The most
consequential of them
is Tucker Carlson. I believe Tucker
Carlson is the single most dangerous
demagogue in this country. And I'll tell
you, I've made the decision that I'm
going to take him on. I believe we are
facing an existential crisis. We are
living
in transformational times.
I will say, Norm, just talked about the
importance of the battle on
anti-Semitism,
but he also said we are winning.
And I applauded for that
because I want us to be winning.
But I'm not sure it is accurate as a
descriptive matter that we are winning
right now.
But we need to fight and I'll tell you
online there are also active deceptions.
There are millions of bots
and there are millions of what are
called sock puppets. Sock puppets are
real people
who talk on other topics but also
deliberately amplify content
that is false and bigoted.
We need to be combating all of that. One
of the steps we should do, by the way,
is social media should identify what
country the poster is coming from.
>> [clears throat]
>> Because there are great many foreign
posters who pretend to be Americans
to dissuade us. And so, I'm honored to
be here to say thank you to everyone
here but also to say
this is not the end of a battle, the end
of a campaign where we can celebrate we
have won. This is rather the beginning
of a battle where our nation, our
beliefs, our constitution, the
principles that built America are under
assault and we need to gird ourselves
for battle and get ready and defeat this
garbage.
All right, let's just
ask one question.
Is it talking about an ideological war?
Yes.
And that's where the problem comes in.
When anybody asks the question
but where do you where do they get the
authority? Where does it come from?
[clears throat]
They are anti-semites or they they're in
trouble. All right. So, Martin, if you
say that biblically
the Jews as a state, as a nation have no
more rule to play a role to play
in biblical prophecy
would you then be called an anti-semite?
According to them, yes.
Now, I can state that quite
categorically. Is that according to the
scripture
the Jewish nation
has no role to play because it rejected
the Messiah?
The Jews as individuals
can accept the Messiah and become part
of the kingdom of God. There's no doubt
about that. The Bible is very clear
about that.
And the gospel has to go to every tribe
and people and nation and tongue.
Does that include the Jews?
>> Yes. And the Muslims? And the Muslims
and the Hindus and the Buddhists and the
Shintoists and all of them.
So,
our contention is we want to take the
gospel to everyone. And the gospel is
very simple.
Accept Jesus Christ as your personal
savior
and obey his precepts, become part of
the kingdom of God
and become part of his future realm.
Well, in the
Tucker recently did quite a few like I
mentioned before, we don't
support Tucker but some of the questions
that he asks is legit questions.
They're legitimate questions. He's
asking the question
all the time, who are the Jews? And then
he gets the way that they treat him. You
heard what Ted Cruz said. We have to
start monitoring these people on social
media from where they are when they say
something.
>> Correct.
So, let's just look at this debate and
we'll come to a conclusion in the end.
So, let's look at what Tucker actually
said when he confronts Mike Huckabee
on the relationship with Israel.
So, let's go through this. You've
appealed to Genesis. Genesis 15 says
it's Abram, it's pre-Abraham, it's Abram
receives from God the news that his
descendants will inherit the land and
you tell me as the as the theologian if
I'm getting this wrong but from the
Euphrates to the Nile.
I think I think that's right.
And that would include like basically
the entire Middle East. That would be
the Levant, so that would be Israel,
Jordan, Syria, Lebanon. It'd also be big
parts of Saudi Arabia and Iraq. It would
be I mean, I'm not sure it would go that
far. I mean, it would be a big piece of
land but here's the point.
>> of con- places that are now countries
that this particular area that we're
talking about now
Israel
is
uh
is a land that God gave through Abraham
to a people that he chose.
It was a people, a place and a purpose.
We we can look at it that way.
Christian Zionism, I want to go back cuz
that's where we started on this.
>> going to let you off on this because you
have said three times that God gave this
land to this people. And so, it is
entirely fair for me with respect to
ask, what land are you talking about?
Because I just read Genesis 15 as I have
many times.
And that land I think it says from the
Nile to the Euphrates, which is
once again basically the entire Middle
East. So, God gave that land to his
people, the Jews or he didn't. You're
saying he did.
What does that mean? Does Israel have
the right to that land? Because you're
appealing to Genesis. You're saying
that's the original deed.
It would be fine if they took it all
but I don't think that's what we're
talking about here today.
>> What would be fine what's exactly we're
talking about today.
>> but here's what I I don't think you're
>> it would be fine if the state of Israel
took over all of Jordan, all of Syria,
all of Lebanon?
>> They're not asking to take it over.
>> But you're saying that the reason that
Israel is legitimate has this inherent
right to exist is bec- in part because
God gave it to his people.
And I am going to the same Bible that
you're referring to and noticing that
that is a huge piece of land. So, if God
gave them that land, then they have a
right to take it now by your definition
unless I'm missing something completely.
>> you're missing something because they're
not asking to go back to take all of
that but they are asking to at least
take the land
that they now occupy, they now live in,
they now own legitimately
and it is a safe haven for them. But may
I ask though as because you're appealing
you're explaining what Christian Zionism
is in your theological beliefs.
And you think you just said it would be
fine with you if the state of Israel
took all of Jordan, all of Syria, all of
Lebanon?
That's that's really not exactly what
I'm trying to say. I think it's a what
you said. I thought that's what you just
said. It was somewhat of a hyperbolic
statement in the you know, if that's
what you feel like that we're talking
about but it isn't.
All right, so there's a serious debate
on this issue, right, Martin?
And
let us make it quite plain.
Modern Israel, the state of modern
Israel is a Masonic construct.
>> Yeah.
It's a Masonic construct.
Who's in control of the Masonic orders
and the secret societies of the world?
The Jesuits. The Jesuits.
And the Knights of Malta and all their
secret nights,
they are in control.
And who do they swear allegiance to? The
Pope.
To the Pope.
So, can we say that the modern state of
Israel is a papal construct?
>> Yeah.
It is not a biblical construct because
Israel consists of those who have
accepted Jesus as the Messiah. If you be
in Christ, you be Abraham's seed and
heirs according to the promise. So,
literal Israel has no biblical role to
play even though people who are
dispensationalists will believe that it
has.
So, let's make that quite clear.
The point then that we have to ask
ourselves is the following.
Why is it there then?
To
bring their plans to fruition.
>> All right, what is their plan?
You can only I can
What is the plan? Why must Israel be
there? Well, it is once again going back
to the Sabbath.
Oh.
Because
they will then be able to keep the
Sabbath according to the Bible.
But they don't have and then the other
ones can adhere to Rome's Sabbath. Okay.
Now, it's very interesting that they
have a law
in their other writings, Talmudic and
otherwise, which very clearly state
that anybody who keeps the Sabbath like
a Jew keeps the Sabbath is actually
deserving of death.
So, is it possible that in this ideology
that any Christian who accepts the
Sabbath
and keeps it like the Jews kept it from
sundown to sundown
is actually deserving of the death
sentence? According to their writings,
yes.
But in their own nation
they would be able to keep the law
as they are keeping it because there's a
very important thing which they are
missing and that's the Messiah. They're
missing Jesus Christ.
And without Christ, there is no
salvation because there's no other way
to the Father except through him.
So,
if they're not going to the Father who
is in heaven, who has a son
then to what father are they paying
allegiance? The father of lies.
Now, Martin, that's a very blatant
statement that you have made there but
that's a scriptural statement. Okay.
Uh
they are deceived.
They are deceived. They actually know
that they are deceived because they have
actually said so, we have missed the 70
week prophecy.
Yeah, that's sad. The time has come and
the time has gone and why is he not
here? Because you missed him. Yeah. You
missed him. That's why he's not there.
So, Martin, we have this situation that
we have a state where the Jews will
continue to wait for a Messiah, keep the
laws according to the scripture, but not
have Jesus as the center. As one of
their Sanhedrin men said, they prefer to
go to Auschwitz rather than accept Jesus
as the Messiah.
Do the Muslims accept Jesus as the son
of God as the Messiah as the atonement?
>> No. No.
So, they're basically in the same boat.
>> Mhm.
Therefore, they can have an Abrahamic
accord.
>> Yeah. Okay? The same with the Roman
Catholics.
>> the Catholics.
So, now you have made room for all of
these religious systems to coexist in a
peaceful accord.
>> Mhm.
In a Fratelli Tutti, a brotherhood
of those opposed to Jesus the only way.
>> Yeah. Right?
>> Yeah.
Okay. Now, the evangelicals are very
confused on this issue.
So, let's have a look what this
gentleman has to say.
And God raised up King Saul and told
Saul, "I want you
to preemptively strike the Amalekites.
I want you to go in
and kill every man,
woman,
boy,
and girl.
And I don't want you to explain it to
Congress. I don't want you to explain it
to anybody. I want you to do
what needs to be done to preserve my
people
a little longer on the face of the
earth.
Now, if King Saul was to do that today,
the entire world would turn against him.
But you see, when God is in something
and a man doesn't care what the world
thinks, he is obeying the dictates of
God himself. When God raised up Donald
Trump, Iran is to America what Amalek
was to Israel, the same thing.
Do we have a mindset in place? Yeah.
Yeah, that's just a very
strong statement that he made.
>> All right. Does
Donald Trump have Christian advisers?
Oh, he's got a whole
department right in the White House. Is
he very strongly aligned to the Roman
Catholic leadership?
>> Yeah, yeah. So, Martin, is he acting on
his own accord or is he acting under
advice? I think he's got
many advisers.
>> Okay.
The point is, Martin,
that there is
a mindset
that any ideology
that interferes with the setting up of a
earthly alliance and a kingdom where the
kings of the world are arrayed against
Christ
as the sole ruler and the only way
is going to get opposition.
>> Mhm.
Now, we've heard what this evangelical
had to say. Let's listen to what this
dominionist has to say.
The majority right now would say, "Well,
the Dark Ages were terrible, you know,
and they're burning witches, you know,
and everybody is oppressed by
Christianity and by, you know, the
clergy and and and it was just this
horrible, horrible time.
Whereas
at that time, the majority would
disagree. The majority during those
centuries would say, 'No, Christendom is
great.
We love Christ. We love his church.
We're making incredible advancements.
We've pushed back on the darkness and on
driven literal demonic spirits out of
northern European tribes and, you know,
places and the Americas and, you know,
all this kind of stuff and making
incredible progress,
incredible discoveries and charting new
maps and
and innovation and inventions. And
so, I'm of the persuasion that I think
the whole idea of the Dark Ages is a
psyop. I think that the Dark Ages was
actually a golden age and that the Great
Enlightenment is actually the dark spell
that has come over the West. And that if
anything, we're in the Dark Ages now.
There's five criteria for voting. Number
one,
America should be a Christian nation.
I'm a Christian nationalist. And so,
yes, I would require a public profession
of faith that you're a Christian in
order to vote. So, my first requirement
before getting into anything else is
faith. It's religion. You should be a
Christian. Well, what kind of Christian,
Joel? A a credal historic creed
Christian. You should publicly affirm
You should have to publicly affirm the
Nicene Creed.
Yeah, the the the Apostles' Creed? Well,
what about Catholics? Could they vote?
Yes.
Well, what about Eastern Orthodox? Yes.
Well, what about Baptists and Anglicans
and Episcopalians and and Presbyterians?
Yes. What about Mormons? No. It's a
cult.
No.
No, they don't believe that Jesus is the
creator.
They believe that he is the first
created.
They believe he's the first created, but
not creator. They're non-Trinitarian.
No, of course, they can't vote. They're
not Christian. Jehovah's Witness? What
about them? Nope, they're not Christian.
Seventh-day Adventist? Nope, they're not
Christian.
It is a cult.
Okay, but what about Muslims?
No way.
What about Jews? No way. Hindus? No way.
Atheists? No way. Well, what about white
European descendants who worship Thor?
No way.
Christian. That's first. All right,
Martin. So, he says you may not be
politically active unless you belong to
the system.
>> Yeah. And he specifically excludes
Seventh-day Adventists and Mormons and
Jehovah's Witnesses and all the rest.
>> Correct. But he accepts the Orthodox
Church and the Catholics because they
accept the creeds.
>> Mhm.
Now, the interesting thing is, as we've
discussed,
that the Orthodox and the Catholics
disagree on the Nicene Creed,
particularly with regard to the specific
role of Jesus Christ. Mhm.
So, even though they disagree,
they can be part of the system,
but the Adventists who believe in the
kingship of Christ are not part of the
system and they're not even Christians
according to him.
>> Mhm.
So, this is as far as it goes. So, who
will be ostracized?
Those that go against them. Those that
don't run along with the system.
>> Yeah. Now, if you knuckle under the
system,
you're still fine. Mhm. But what if you
go against it and you say you will not
accept the law Mhm. that the Christians
are putting in place because you only
accept the law as it is in the Bible.
Who becomes your enemy?
Everybody. The state.
Will the Jews become your enemy? Because
you're not allowed to keep the Sabbath
if you are not a Jew.
>> Mhm. Will the Christians be against you?
Yes, because you have to keep Sunday,
you can't keep the Sabbath.
So, [snorts] Martin, what about the
Mormons? Don't they keep Sunday?
>> So, they could receive the mark on their
hand
>> Yeah. and be quite happy to fall into
the system. What about the Jehovah's
Witnesses? Don't they do the same? They
just deny the divinity of Christ, right?
>> Mhm.
So, Martin, there you have a system
where one group is mentioned that
accepts the divinity of Christ, accepts
the kingship of Christ, accepts the
rulership of Christ, accepts the
atonement of Christ, accepts obedience
to his law because if you love me, keep
my commandments,
>> Mhm.
they're not Christians.
So, what are these others then? Aren't
they then Babylon that has fallen, that
has fallen because they refuse to accept
everything that the Bible says?
>> Yeah.
Okay. Now, Martin, this is getting very
interesting. So, let's move on. Uh John
Gill, uh he held that both tables of the
law, so that being, you know, 1 through
4 with the 10 Commandments as well as 5
through 10,
um are Commandments as it pertains to
God, the Sabbath, Sabbath, Sabbath, not
taking his the the name of the Lord in
vain and and etc. Uh that these are
actually binding and should be
legislated and upheld by the civil
magistrate. So, not just the civil
magistrate enforcing that we don't steal
from our neighbor or murder our
neighbor, those kinds of things, but
that the civil magistrate actually has a
God-given duty, invested interest in
seeing to it that the nation, that the
country uh does not commit blasphemy.
So, Martin, clearly he says that they
want to legislate the law.
>> Yeah. And they want to legislate the
first table of the law,
>> Mhm.
but they want to have Sunday. Yeah.
Yeah, Douglas Wilson also very clearly
said he
>> said exactly the same thing. Let's just
refresh our memories.
>> How much of an incrementalist are you?
Uh do you
does your ideal political leader get
into power and then shoot the moon,
um Sabbath legislation,
um the whole deal? Or do you
wait in from the shallow end? You don't
need you don't actually don't need like
a majority support of population, you
just need a strong-willed minority. And
then the that ruling class can shape the
imagination of the majority, which I
think Trump is doing now because for
decades we've had a very kind of weak
right when it comes to imposing your
will upon the executive branch.
And now he's actually revealing to the
country that oh wait, there is this
executive who who's vested with the
executive power who can exercise power
within his branch. Um I I just don't
think you're you're ever going to escape
the nature of politics which is
agonistic. There's a struggle. There's a
point which you you debate and then if
and then if you win, you win and you
essentially impose your will upon those
who disagree. Okay. So, Martin the
Sabbath is becoming the issue, right?
Because it is the
the very core of authoritarianism.
>> Yeah. As to why you have the right to
dictate morality. This is the core
issue.
But it is the mark of the beast. Mhm. It
is the papal sign. So, we have to hear
what the Pope has to say. Yeah. Now, how
militant are they prepared to go?
Let's just listen to what Mark Meckler
has to say on the issue.
I think the most important thing that
the church has done that's very damaging
is we've traded righteousness and truth
for empathy and tolerance. And the
highest value in most of the churches
that I visit now is empathy and
tolerance. That's true. And it's empathy
and tolerance for evil and intolerance.
And this is something that I said that's
I think it's become controversial. You
probably get letters complaining about
this. We have to become a lot less
tolerant.
We are way too tolerant as a people and
a nation.
>> [applause]
>> And look, there's biblical precedent for
that. They didn't tolerate this kind of
this kind of behavior in in ancient
Israel. They didn't tolerate it in
Jesus' time. Jesus was very direct about
this kind of stuff. We teach this
incredibly nice sanitized version, I
would say an effeminized version of
Jesus. This is a man who who made a cat
of nine tails and went in to kick the
tables over and screamed at people and
called them vipers for sinning, for
doing terrible things against the law of
God and we don't do that as a nation
anymore. And instead what we do is like,
"Oh, if the Boy Scouts are going gay,
that's their problem." And it's not
maybe I'll pull my kids out, but I'm
worried about pulling my kids out
because maybe people will think I'm
intolerant, right? No, we need to be a
lot more intolerant. If you look at the
history of the United States of America
and you look at the founding of this
country, I'm not suggesting we should do
this, but back at the founding of this
country before we were a nation, most
states, colonies back then had laws that
required you to be in church on Sunday.
Right? They were not tolerant of
non-believers. And so this idea that we
should just accept everybody and
everything, that's a modern idea. It
comes from Satan and it is destroying
our country. So, Martin, is that going
back to the Middle Ages? Well, does that
sound like the Sunday law that can be
implemented? It certainly does. telling
them telling people about so long. Is Is
America therefore becoming Catholic? Oh,
definitely.
>> Let's have a look. The National Catholic
Prayer Breakfast stands as a visible
[music] reminder
that faith and public life
are not separate.
>> We commend to your mercy the souls of
the founding fathers and all past
presidents. We entrust to the protection
of your mother Mary those serving in our
armed forces and to her intercession
civil discourse in our nation and
lasting peace in our world. For the sake
of his sorrowful passion
have mercy on us and on the whole world.
For the sake of his sorrowful passion
>> With these sentiments, I entrust all of
those present to the intercession of
Mary Immaculate
and St. Joseph, her most chaste spouse.
>> Hallow is the number one Catholic app in
the world. Hallow has made it not only
easier for people who already know how
to pray to pray more easily, but for
those who are unfamiliar with structured
prayer to learn how to do that in a
completely accessible and
non-threatening way.
>> Last December, I was the first president
to commemorate the feast of the
Immaculate Conception. Today, I'm also
proud to be the first president to honor
the feast of St. Joseph in recognition
of one of the greatest saints to ever
live. And I'm pleased to say report that
just last night, Congress unanimously
gave unanimous consent to set aside this
May 17th uh as a national day of prayer
and fasting. Hatred toward Jewish people
is ugly, despicable, an affront to the
Sacred Heart of Jesus. Not only is the
sitting vice president Catholic, but
every presently viable candidate for
president in 2028 of both parties is a
baptized Catholic. Few of our
forefathers could have predicted it.
Only a firm faith in providence could
have permitted it. And yet, here we find
ourselves a quarter millennium later, a
people and a place so improbably and
perfectly suited for each other that not
only can a Catholic become president,
but an American can even be the Pope.
Thank you very much. There's some very
angry voices out there trying to
convince us [music] breathlessly that
there must be a rigid separation between
church and state.
It's a phrase that's often repeated as
we know, but very rarely understood.
Now, they take that phrase and they turn
it around.
Jefferson clearly did not mean that wall
to keep religion from influencing our
government public life. To the contrary,
the founders wanted to protect the
church
and the religious practice of citizens
>> [music]
>> from an encroaching state, not the other
way around.
Our founders understood that a free
society and a healthy republic depend
upon religious and moral virtue,
not only because these things help
prevent the abuse of power,
but also because those convictions make
it possible to preserve our essential
freedoms. [music]
So, Martin,
are we going back to healing the wound
of Catholicism? You know that um
statement that also says that Protestant
America will
grasp grasp and grab the hand of
Catholicism. You can see it very
clearly.
And uh this series with Jonathan Roumie
uh as Christ,
he tells us here that he has this
intense spiritual toll of filming
Christ's crucifixion for the chosen.
That's the hardest thing I've ever done
in my life, both professionally and
personally as a human being.
And then, what is this story about him
as a devout Catholic and the heavy
physical and emotional toll that it took
on him?
He says the following, "I spent a lot of
time asking the Lord to show me what he
wanted people to see
and he wanted them to experience and if
it was at all possible for me
to try to experience a fraction of a
fraction of what he went through.
And I was willing to offer myself in
that way and he gave me some really
challenging experiences and set on set
physically and emotionally. And
basically, he's implying that it can
contribute in a small way
to uh atoning for people. This is
basically what the treasury
in Roman Catholicism does because it can
scoop from the merit and the pain of the
saints and attribute it to you as an
indulgence.
Martin, this is a absolute denying of
the absolute complete full complete
sacrifice of Jesus Christ.
This is Catholicism at its best. And
then, they're propagating ritualistic
prayer where you read out of prayer
books.
>> Yeah.
And uh you become ritualized.
Prayer is having a conversation with God
as your friend.
>> Mhm. It is a personal issue. It's not a
ritual. Once it becomes ritualized, you
have lost entirely the relationship.
>> There's no formula
that you can adhere to. So, I have to do
10 of this, five of this, three of this
and then God will listen to me.
>> Then finally, I'll listen to you or tie
yourself into a knot into a lotus
position so that you can finally see
well, you you really mean business. Or
read a passage 100 times over and over
and over and over.
Do not be like the pagans that repeat
over and over again. So, Martin, this is
pure Catholicism creeping in
and it is a Catholic mindset. Now, how
far is this going to go?
Who can trump Trump?
An unlikely candidate is emerging, the
Catholic Church. No.
He is the Catholic Church's proxy. Did
he not kneel before the statue of John
Paul II?
>> He is the proxy.
>> mentioned many times he's the most pro
Catholic president that there ever was.
What the US urgently needs now,
metaphorically speaking, is a national
champion, a sort of modern-day St.
George to slay the dragon, save the
people, ensure the triumph of good over
evil.
Who in reality might fill this role of
moral savior? Step forward, Leo the
13th. the American Pope.
Are we there? Uh for sure.
All right, let's try and wrap up this
issue of this war in Iran
and get to some of the nitty-gritty.
Now, this man that we're going to look
at next in this video is a man who was
leading the counterterrorism
organization in the Americas
and he resigned recently Kent.
And it caused a great who-ha.
Now he had a discussion with Tucker
Carlson.
And it's interesting what he has to say.
Let's just listen to some of the aspects
besides speaking about the war in Iran
and why it should never have taken place
and why he resigned and all of those
issues. There are some very interesting
things
that he says which we should take
cognizance of.
Um and then you know Charlie Kirk is
killed publicly in a very horrific way
and we're not really even allowed to
look into that at all. And Charlie Kirk
was one of President Trump's closest
advisers and he also advocated heavily
against a war with Iran. He was in the
Oval Office in the lead up to the 12-day
war. I I wasn't particularly close with
Charlie. He was very gracious to me when
I was running for Congress, very very
supportive. Uh so we knew each other and
the last time I saw Charlie Kirk on this
earth was [snorts] in in June um in in
the in the West Wing in the stairway and
I said hi to him and he looked me in the
eye and he said very loudly and it's a
small you've been in the West Wing it's
it's small.
Uh it's a tight space and and he said
Joe stop us from getting into a war with
Iran.
Very loudly.
>> He was single-minded.
>> walked off and he went I believe into
the Oval.
Um so when one of President Trump's
closest advisers who is vocally
advocating
for us to not go to war with Iran and
for us to rethink at least our
relationship with the Israelis.
Um and then he suddenly publicly
assassinated and we're not allowed to
ask any questions about that.
It's a data point. It's a data point
that we need to look into. What do you
mean um
when you say we're not allowed to ask
any questions about that? Would you
we've we've been told that this
individual
uh Robinson is a lone gunman and maybe
he is.
Um but the investigation that that I was
a part of the National Counterterrorism
Center was a part of. We were stopped
from continuing to investigate. And the
FBI will say that that they stopped that
because
they wanted to have every turn
everything over to the Utah state
authorities and everything's going to
trial it's very very sensitive.
But there were still a lot for us to
look into that I I I can't really get
into but there was still linkage for us
to investigate that we needed to run
down. And I'm not making any
conclusions. I'm not saying
>> No, I don't think you are.
>> because you know because of this this
happened. I'm not I'm not saying that at
all. I'm just saying there's unanswered
questions. We know the pressure because
of the text messages that text messages
that have been made public that Charlie
was under a lot of pressure from a lot
of pro-Israel donors. And again we know
Charlie was advocating to President
Trump against this war
with Iran. And we knew at the end of the
12-day war at the end of Midnight Hammer
that the Israelis were going to come
back and ask us to go back to war
again. Right.
There are two issues here now.
He is saying that Charlie Kirk advocated
against a war with Iran.
But he did something else as well. He
advocated for
as the Sabbath.
And he explained that he keeps the
Sabbath like the Jews keep the Sabbath.
>> Mhm.
Now is that permissible in Jewish
thinking? No, from what you've explained
earlier. No.
>> No.
So there are two issues.
Would that if he adhered to the way in
which the Jews keep the Sabbath and
adhered to the day on which they kept
the Sabbath
would that [snorts] be a problem for the
Christian world as well? Yes.
Yeah, because they want Sunday. All
right. So there were two issues.
Now he's not saying but he is implying
that there's more to the death of
Charlie Kirk than meets the eye.
And he is actually implying that there
might be some Israeli involvement.
Because this particular mindset is
problematic
not only for the Jew
and the Jewish Zionist idea it's also
problematic for the Christians.
>> Yeah.
Now his wife has she mentioned the way
in which the Jews keep the Sabbath or is
she advocating for Sunday? For Sunday.
So
>> Because she's a Roman Catholic.
Sudden switch, right?
>> [clears throat]
>> Yeah, when they brought out and we've
shown the um
memorial service and everything she
clearly advocated for the Sunday and the
next Sunday.
>> So Charlie Kirk had two problems. Number
one he advocated against this kind of
war.
So he was advocating against this um
Jewish expansion.
And basically by implication against the
Abrahamic Accord maybe in a sense.
And secondly
he was advocating something that was
problematic to the Christians.
And so he's throwing it out there is
there more involved than meets the eye.
Now this is a very interesting
discussion where uh
Tucker Carlson is talking about this war
and about Israel and he's talking to a
person from a Chinese perspective.
Now this person has some very
interesting things to say besides the
economic impact and all of these issues.
He's saying that a new order can come
out of this but he's also asking some
interesting questions. Let's just watch
it.
What I would do is basically sit down
everyone okay including Russia, China,
Iran and say it's time for a new world
order where we are partners in this
relationship. Right before America was a
hegemon before the US dollar was a world
reserve currency.
Uh but now what we want to do is open a
dialogue where everyone is respected
where
um America's is no longer the bully but
a willing partner in creating a new
economic order that benefits everyone
and not just and not just a few.
Um Israel no longer behaves rationally.
It is sort of overtaken by
eschatological fever. Right? So if you
look at uh videos coming out of Israel
there are rabbis going around saying
that this war in the Middle East even
though it's destroying Tel Aviv um it's
good for us because this will lead to
the to the coming of our Messiah.
Um so they believe that it is when
Israel is under the most strain when
Israel
when the very existence of Israel is
threatened then God will intervene
because the Jewish people will come
together as a nation again and commit
themselves renew their faith in God. And
once God sees the
um blind trusting absolute faith of the
Jewish people then he will save his
people by sending his Messiah who will
then redeem the um
uh Jewish people. So in other words
saying this is secular
temporal matters don't really matter.
This war in the Middle East not an
issue. What matters is divinity. What
matters is our relationship with God.
Yes.
>> So what matters is faith. If nuclear
bombs go flying doesn't really matter.
I I don't think we can
ever overestimate the influence of
eschatology in American politics. So
I'll I'll give you an example where a
lot of quarter of Americans are evangel-
evangelical. And and a lot of them are
Christian Zionists. Um so they believe
that Israel is crucial the linchpin to
achieving God's plan of and the return
of Jesus. And so a very prominent figure
that you probably know very well is John
Hagee who runs something called the
Christians United for Israel. It's 7
million um
um members and these are the people who
are
financing a lot of the conflict in uh
the Middle East
um in Israel because they're the ones
who are funding West Bank settlements.
And so Christian Zionism it is an
extremely powerful political force in
in America. So um your question is
how did this happen? Um And
>> Yes.
>> Look the the issue the issue is that
this is a plan
um that has been in motion for
centuries.
And it's a very complicated um um
uh history but it involves
um
uh different religious groups among the
Jews Satmar Frankist Chabad Lubavitch
which you've talked about but also it
involves the Freemasons the Knights
Templars the Rosicrucians it involves
the Jesuits. So you have these different
um
different secret societies different
religious organizations working together
for the centuries to achieve this plan
for the end of the world which heralds
the Messianic age okay? And there are
different components of this plan
but but the basic components are one is
the
um creation of the state the nation
state of Israel which happened in 1948
48. And then you you need to have um
the building of the third temple which
requires the destruction of the Al-Aqsa
mosque which is actually um which could
happen during this war um
They also talk about this war of Gog and
Magog uh between Israel and the entire
world um then the coming of the Jewish
Messiah
um the creation of the Greater Israel
project the return of all Jews from the
diaspora. Um so so there are different
components to this plan. If you just
observed geopolitical events
we're seeing these events converge
together today. I mean, all these events
are playing out. So, it seems as though
there are these very powerful shadow
forces working behind the scenes. We
don't know who they are, but it seems as
though they're able to control
geopolitics in a certain manner as to
fulfill
um their uh escatolo- escatological
script.
Martin, do you think he watched Total
Onslaught? I'm sure there is Well, if he
didn't
then the information is very accurate
and the same. Yes.
And um
we I don't
even what's a prof. We He can carry on
for now.
Yes, I think we must get this man on
board. We must uh get a little bit more
information. So, Martin, this has been
coming for centuries.
It is a construct of setting up an
earthly system of coexistence.
It is a system where the Christian world
rules the Christian world, the Muslim
world rules the Muslim world, and the
Jewish world
gets a state and the Jews return to
their state.
He mentioned the temple. He said, "Even
that uh mosque at the moment
could be destroyed by some
rocket or appears to be
>> Appeared to be, yeah. Yeah, destroyed by
some rocket so that the Jewish temple
can be rebuilt. It's a possibility.
Whether it works that way or not, uh
there's enough room on the Temple Mount
to build the temple even if the mosque
remains.
So, these are all very interesting
factors.
So, let us just sum it up again. This
war
is to eradicate any thinking that will
get rid of the peaceful coexistence.
It is the eradication of extremist view
views of
uh my way is way and
and all others must be eliminated. You
can't have a world and a common good
with that mindset. But just interesting,
that's so contradictory because they say
their way is the only way. Correct.
Then the final enemy is anyone who
opposes this unity.
And when they introduce the law, as they
say, and they want to legislate the
first
table of the law
then those that honor the Sabbath become
the pariah not only for the Jews, but
also for the Christians.
So, let's just make it quite clear that
the papacy, the evangelical world, is
pushing for Sunday legislation. You
heard it. And that the Christians must
actually keep Sunday, right?
And we had an interview
where they told us quite clearly that
Seventh-day Adventists had better change
their mind and start coming into harmony
with Sunday.
>> That will be much easier and it will be
a lot less painful. If I go.
So, let's make it quite clear again that
Rome is very adamant that most
Christians assume that Sunday is the
biblically approved day of worship. The
Roman Catholic Church protests
that it transferred Christian worship
from the biblical Sabbath Saturday to
Sunday
and that to try to argue that the change
was made in the Bible is both dishonest
and denial of Catholic authority. It's
all about authority.
If Protestantism wants to base its
teachings only on the Bible, it should
worship on Saturday.
In fact, Rome has made it absolutely
clear that the only consistent
Protestant in the world is the
Seventh-day Adventist.
>> Because they adhere to the Bible.
Correct. They've made it quite clear.
So, they are saying
that by accepting Sunday, you're
accepting the authority of the Catholic
Church.
By accepting the Sabbath, you accept the
authority of Jesus Christ now.
So, Martin, this Pope, is he pushing for
Sunday? Now, here's an article that came
out on the 15th of March, 2026,
and it comes directly from the Vatican
webpage. So, this is absolutely legit.
It says homily. It says homily.
So,
parish of the Sacred Heart of Jesus. Do
they want to dedicate America to the
Sacred Heart of Jesus?
>> Yes, and behind Correct.
>> If you go a little bit further, it's
actually to the Immaculate Heart of
Mary.
>> Now, at that prayer breakfast, did you
hear the speeches by the nuns? Wasn't it
Mary, Mary, Mary, Mary? That's pure
Catholicism.
Okay.
So, what was his homily about?
In the interrogation to which the blind
man who can
now see is subjected
it is above all Jesus who is put on
trial, accused of having violated the
Sabbath in order to heal him.
Thus, another form of blindness is
revealed in those present, one that is
different and even more serious.
That of failing to see.
Right before their eyes, the face of God
for which they trade the possibility
of saving encounter for the sterile
security afforded by the legalistic
observance
of a formal discipline.
Faced with such obtuseness, Jesus does
not stop showing that no Sabbath can
stand in the way of an act of love.
After all, the meaning of the Sabbath,
the rest for the people of Israel and
for us on Sunday
the Lord's Day, is precisely to
celebrate the mystery of life as a gift,
in the face of which no one can ignore
the cry for help from a brother or
sister who is suffering.
So, for the Christians, he says, Sunday
is the day.
>> Yeah.
Are we there? We there. We've heard it
from the You've heard it now from the
Pope. You've heard it from uh Douglas
Wilson. Um who's a Christian
nationalist. So, it's the Protestant
side and the
Catholic side that says the same. Now,
once this war in Iran has been concluded
according to the assessment of our
Chinese friend
he said there can become there can come
a new order.
A new order in which fairness presides,
in which Russia can be incorporated,
and peace can preside on Earth, and
maybe, you know, Russia can be
re-included into society. The war there
must end, and we must enter a time of
peace.
The ideologies which speak of
exclusivity in terms of salvation have
been removed. The Abrahamic Accord can
be implemented, and the Jews can have
their homeland and their temple.
Which is a denial of the Messiah.
The Christians can rule in Christian
lands.
>> [snorts]
>> And those that want to keep the Sabbath
like the Jews will have to become Jews.
If they want to remain Christians, they
will have to be eliminated.
>> Yeah.
So, there will be a death decree
eventually. First economic measures,
then a death decree. Is the United
States, on behalf of the first beast
implementing the ideology of the Jesuits
in terms of the Jewish state and the new
religious dispensation in the world?
>> Yeah. Yeah. Definitely. I was thinking
what you mentioned just now on if you
want to be keep the Sabbath, you have to
go to become a Jew
or go to Israel. Um
it's the same like you've mentioned in
your previous lectures on
the cantons. The Protestant canton and
the Catholic canton. If you wanted to
become a
you had to move. Otherwise, you were
killed in the You had to move, yes.
Absolutely. That's what happened in the
Middle Ages. So, the stage is set set
for dominionism
to rule, a Catholic form of dominionism
with a brotherhood coexistence with all
the kings of the world that are arrayed
against Christ.
Now, Martin, what about the atheistic
world? What about the Chinese? They're
not a problem.
Because they don't accept Jesus Christ.
The Jews don't accept Jesus Christ. The
Muslims don't accept Jesus Christ as the
Son of God, as God in the flesh, and as
the atonement.
So, there is an accord against Christ.
And against those that keep the
commandments of God and have the faith
of Jesus. This is what this war is
about. It is the final step, in my
opinion
towards this final eradication of any
contra ideology.
Any ideology that stands in the way of
the grand Jesuit plot
>> Yeah. to subject the entire world to the
authority of the man in Rome.
>> Mhm. Let's pray. Let's pray.
Heavenly Father
we are seeing the culmination of
history.
We are seeing an alignment of the kings
of the world. We are seeing elimination
of any mindset
that is contrary to this ideology,
whether it is the ideology as it is
portrayed in Iran
or whether it is the ideology as
portrayed in the mind of a Charlie Kirk
portrayed in the mind of those that want
to keep the commandments of God as they
stand
and have the faith of Jesus.
And the only one that we can rely on to
save us in these circumstances
is the king of kings and lord of lords
who has promised to return
and to
get rid of all the kingdoms that have
aligned themselves against the son of
God.
Give us courage to stand for [music]
righteousness and truth in Jesus' name.
Amen. Amen.
>> [music]
[music]